c'était sur la chanson toute première
fois de jeunes massa alors ça c'est
mignon ça c'est ça c'est un regret
chaîne non non non kelly kelly non non
est-ce que ça ça parait mon raymond
alain genre à fumer dans les bars la
moitié n'ont donc il est quoi quoi quoi
la première fois qu'il a fêté ses 84
bah oui dans 84 ne s'agit pas la
longueur et donc ouais et les chéris
c'est là comment ces stars mais bon quoi
c'était et tant qu'à vélo est ami avec
elle agit dans la bêtise en eau non mais
non c'est pas possible vos coups plus
tard en fait non mais c'est une chose
est ce que la chanson elle aussi fait
vrai et il ya quand même le prix nobel
de l'émission qui vient de venir vous
avez mis du temps comme pour voir sa
lancée elle a une tête alors doc gynéco
vous avez donc fait l'amour pour la
première fois sur toute première fois
déjà de masse sur ça
[Musique]
voir
et de tout faire
à mon avis à mon avis alors doc
j'aimerais que tu nous racontes ça parce
que ça je le sens très très bien
cammas est ce que tu as déjà fait
l'amour sur une de tes chansons en fait
en fait en fait la première fois que
j'ai entendu ma chanson à la radio toute
première fois en effet j'étais avec un
très beau garçon et et qui était
également un artiste que je ne
reviendrai pas et j'ai dit que je passe
avant toi non mais non c'était très bête
mais ouais c'est oui c'est un art comme
ça c'est un scoop ça vous étiez avec un
artiste oui mais bon c'est raté
maintenant on n'a pas ces mots faut pas
essayer de savoir si pendant la pub mais
pas mais pas de musique
non c'est vrai non j'aime pas ouais
ouais ça déconcentre et ouais bah moi je
vais souvent il tape sur des bambous de
[Applaudissements]
doc gynéco j'aimerais que tu nous
racontes ta première fois sur jeanne mas
parce que ça je pensais sans moi doc
gynéco
vous pouvez nous raconter votre première
fois parce que votre première fois vous
l'avez fait sur le titre de jeanne mas
toute première fois oui non en fait
c'est une chanson qui a voyagé dans le
temps et qui m'a permise en quelque
sorte de 200 me rendre compte de
peut-être il serait possible que j'ai
été inspiré par votre titre parce que
lorsqu'on m'a appelé qu'on m'a dit oui
quand était la première fois je ne
savais pas que vous veniez et j'ai dit
bah alors toute première fois on n'est
pas l'ordre quand on les appelait
indiqué pour que pourquoi on te demander
ta première fois tu n'as pas demandé qui
était l'invité je savais pas que c'est
acquis chanter cette chanson c'est que
c'était black m
[Rires]
d'appel que j'embrasse alors donc était
resté sur un rocher noir qui est arrivé
après alors vous avez on n'a pas fait
qu'un petit train vous sinon on serait
resté sur vannes x1 un intrus mais il ya
plein d'autres alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter notre votre
première fois il faudrait que je puisse
m'en souvenir c'est comme kelly elle m'a
dit je me rappelle pas de la première
fois j'ai fait l'amour maniche presse je
me rappelle que de ce que j'ai montré ce
soir là alors me souviens pas de la
première fois tu te fous de ma gueule
secours mais les nerfs mais tu t'en
souviens bas bien sûr je m'en souviens
quand j'étais en veut savoir
j'étais je suis en train d'inventer avec
une sublime mannequin sud américaine
julia de gina que j'embrasse non c'est à
oran sans l'appeler orangina parce qu'on
la supprime beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et voilà j'ai promis voilà mes bons jeux
mais voilà ces dessins vous l'avez oui
bien sûr et je peux vous dire que la
poulpe n'est pas resté à la mairie sera
jamais allé non merci
elle raconte la deuxième fois la
dernière feuille bon peut-être que
c'était avec n'ont même pas parce que la
première fille avec laquelle j'étais
j'avais pas couché avec elle
d'accord mais là c'est la première tv
qui vous avez couché c'est à quel âge on
va tous rentrer depuis le début génial
c'était à quel âge en plus vous zappez
doc gynéco j'ai quand même un monde
j'ai fui la moindre idée de ce assez
incroyable et moi mais vous êtes qui
mais sans rigoler ferro tu as fait des
tests de mémoire c'est un truc que j'ai
occulté
est ce que tu te souviens de ce que tu
as fait alors on va les plus impactants
on va juste tester ta mémoire oublie
tout est histoire de première fois et la
dernière
non pas du tout qu'as tu fait nous
sommes jeudi que tu fais jeudi dernier
alors je crois qu'on a tous d'ici ne se
souvient pas de ce qu'il a fait jeudi
dernier et j'en ai mal je vais poser une
autre question qu'as tu fait hier et
hier après midi
en fait je n'arrive qu'à avancer
j'arrive pas dur tu te souviens même pas
tout ce que tu as fait hier après midi
quatre cas tu buvais après midi
[Applaudissements]